>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Helena Zinkham: Good
afternoon, everyone.
I'm Helena -- yes, good afternoon.
[laughter] Wake ourselves
after lunch a little bit.
I'm Helena Zinkham, director
for Collections and Services,
as well as chief of the Prints
and Photographs Division here
at the Library of Congress.
And it's my genuine pleasure
this afternoon to welcome you
to a special program featuring
Bob Adelman and Ira Glasser.
They're going to talk about
their book "Visions of Liberty."
The subject matter is actually
quite serious, isn't it?
Human right, civil
rights, civil liberties.
But these are two imminent,
life-long advocates for justice,
who happen to be quite
lively speakers as well.
So this topic is going to come
alive for us this afternoon.
Back in 1991, when Bob and Ira --
documentary photographer Bob Adelman
and American Civil Liberties
Union president Ira Glasser,
they teamed up for a book
called "Visions of Liberty,"
honoring the 200th anniversary
of the American Bill of Rights.
Now almost 25 years later,
I'm looking forward to hearing
if you think we've made progress
or not, but we're also here
to celebrate the 800th
anniversary of the Magna Carta
and the 50th anniversary
of the Civil Rights Act.
That's a lot of anniversaries
colliding, isn't it?
Piling up.
And they too will help us both
appreciate the achievements
and how much further down
the road we have to go
to actually reach social justice.
To introduce you in a more
formal way to our speakers,
you have wonderful biographies in
your program, so I am just going
to mention briefly, on behalf of the
videotape, that Bob Adelman is one
of the foremost photographers
of the Civil Rights Movement.
Born in New York City in 1930,
he grew up on Long Island
and has degrees from Rutgers,
Harvard, and Columbia.
He studied photography with Alexi
Brodovitch, the famed art director
of Harper's Bazaar Magazine.
With an avid interest in social and
political events of the early 1960s,
Bob was drawn to the sit-ins
staged by young students
across the American south.
He volunteered to take photos of
the demonstrations for the Congress
of Racial Equality, CORE, and
has continued to be involved
with Civil Rights issues and
the human condition ever since.
In 2014, Bob was invited to
serve at the Library of Congress
as a consulting photographer,
to expand awareness
of our visual collections.
Thank you for that.
[ Applause ]
Ira Glasser served with the American
Civil Liberties Union for 34 years,
executive director
from 1978 until 2001.
Glasser has published widely
on civil liberty principles,
as well as issues.
His writings have appeared in the
New York Times, Washington Post,
Village Voice, Harper's, New
Republic Nation, Christianity,
and Crisis, along many others.
He's also been a frequent
guest and debater on such radio
and television shows as William
F. Buckley's Firing Line.
Born and raised in New York, Glasser
achieved a bachelors in mathematics
from Queens College and
a masters in mathematics
from Ohio State University.
A few words of thanks,
first to the Prints
and Photographs Division
staff, the Law Library staff,
and the Interpretive Programs Office
staff, who collaborated seamlessly
to bring a lot of disparate
parts together
for our program this afternoon.
To see more of their talented
work, please be sure to take a look
at the very popular Law
Library blog, In Custodia Legis.
The valuable Vision Materials
blog, called Picture This.
And of course, the Civil
Rights Act exhibition,
which is up in the
Jefferson Building all the way
through January.
I also want to acknowledge
Roberta Shaffer.
Are you here today?
There you go.
[laughter].
So quiet in the middle.
Roberta, our inspirational
leader, a library leader.
Former law librarian, associate
librarian for Library Services.
But most importantly today, the
personal sponsor for this project.
Mr. Adelman's consultancy and
photography at the library is funded
through Roberta, a
self-described futurist.
And here's one thing
I admire a great deal.
Roberta, you see connections
that build a stronger future
direction for all of us.
I don't think I ever would
have thought of the potential
for combining well-reasoned law
with the artistry of photography,
and yet you knew how
to make it happen
so that there are creative
agents together
to make sure the world
changes and grows better.
Robert -- [applause].
Great, thank you.
So we almost called this
the Program of the Roberts.
We have our sponsor, Roberta.
Our wonderful chief of
staff, Robert Newlen.
Bob. Would you like a new
middle name today, Ira?
[laughter]
>> Bob Adelman: You're outnumbered.
>> Helena Zinkham: So more seriously
then, our wonderful chief of staff,
Robert Newlen, formerly associate
law librarian and mastermind
for the Magna Carta exhibition.
You're going to tap your three
worlds of expertise, law, art,
history, as a great moderator
for our program today.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Robert Newlen: Thank you
Helena, for that nice introduction.
It beats the last introduction
I had at a program recently.
Maybe some of you were there.
I was introduced as Robert
Newlen, who has been chief of staff
at the Library of Congress,
since December 1914.
[laughter].
And I said, "That's why I
remember the Russian Revolution."
So Helena, thank you.
That was really very nice.
I think it's very appropriate today
that this program is
entitled Visions of Liberty.
And I would also like to
acknowledge Roberta Shaffer
and making programs
like this possible.
And Roberta, we owe you a great deal
and are just very grateful for all
that you have and are doing
for the Library of Congress.
With that said, it's a little
intimidating to be sitting
with two extremely iconic gentlemen
in the areas of civil liberties
and social justice, but here I am.
And here's how I propose
that we spend the next hour,
or whatever we have left now.
We're going to start off talking
a little bit about how this,
my dog-eared copy of "Visions
of Liberty: The Bill of Rights
for All Americans," came about.
And then we're going to move to
Bob's photographs in several areas.
And it's really Sophie's choice,
trying to choose photographs
that we want to talk about today,
but thanks to Verna
Curtis, we have done that.
And so gentlemen, I'm going to
open the question to you now.
How did this book come about?
How did this collaboration start?
And spare no details.
>> Ira Glasser: Well, he goes
like this, but it was his idea.
[laughter] And those of you
who may not know him know
that he is pathologically
stubborn about his ideas.
And he proposed this book to
me many times over many years,
and each time he did, I
told him it was impossible.
I couldn't do it, I
couldn't work with him.
I already had a job as the
ACLU executive director
that occupied me 95 hours a
week, and what spare time I had,
I was trying to reserve for
my children so that they could
at least remember who I was.
And he acknowledged that, a man of
great feeling, and then said, "Yeah,
but it's a really important book.
We really should do it.
There isn't a book like it."
This went on, and on,
and on, and on.
And I kept successfully
resisting it.
Then it got to be close to 1991 and
the 200th anniversary, and he said,
"This is really a compelling
time to do it."
And I resisted it again.
It was impossible, I couldn't do it.
So he said, "Well, maybe we can get"
-- you know, it was really supposed
to be a book of photographs
with captions
or maybe a paragraph caption.
And so he said, "Well, maybe we can
get somebody to write the captions
and to write the paragraphs,"
and we thought of a few people.
And I asked Kurt Vonnegut
if he would do it,
because he was a big ACLU supporter.
And he said, "No, you should do it.
I don't know enough about this."
And this went on, and on, and on.
We couldn't find anybody to do it.
And finally, I don't remember
how, I agreed to do it.
And then somewhere along the
way, because as you can tell,
even by my story now, I'm
not a man of few words,
what happened is it turned out
from being a book of photographs
with captions to being a
book of text with photos.
And then Bob basically
produced the book
with Richard Seaver
of Arcade Publishing.
And I must say, I'm glad I gave it.
And having the opportunity
to sort of put
on paper what I had been talking
about to countless audiences
and trying to explain the importance
and origins of our basic values
of liberty in this country,
and having it accompanied
by the really glittering array
of photographs that we were able
to assemble, most of which
were Bob, and the others
that weren't his were ones
that he found and selected,
was a great privilege and a great
joy, and I still love to leaf
through all those pictures.
And they illustrate
things that words can't,
and that has been Bob's
great genius, in my view,
in tracking so many
movements of social justice
in this country as he has.
So you have a right to reply,
if you have a different view,
but that was how I [inaudible].
>> Well, I think the -- I think one
thing that we should all be aware
of is that, at the
time, if you remember,
it was a very vivid
political process
that the Constitution was
celebrated, the 200th anniversary
of the Constitution was celebrated.
And Ira reminded me, it
was not the Bill of Rights
that was being celebrated,
but the Constitution itself.
And when we published this book,
there was very little public
acclaim for the Bill of Rights.
Now, the reason I was always
so persistent in getting
after Ira was because, first of all,
I didn't know anybody who knew more
about the Bill of Rights and had
more penetrative things to say.
But I envisioned somehow
photographing all these landmark
decisions and, you know, all the
social processes that led up to it.
As it turned out, once
I got into it,
it was extremely difficult
to photograph.
For instance, I wanted to photograph
the tension of an immigrant
or something, and getting permission
to go to Miami at that time,
where they were retaining a lot of
Cubans, it was virtually impossible.
I couldn't get in, you know.
So it was really very unfortunate.
Yet my experiences are
that, for most Americans,
the Bill of Rights is what
it means to be an American.
And as Ira brilliantly points
out in the book, it is the place
that individuals interact
with government,
and it's extraordinary individuals
who've won for us our freedom,
our growing freedoms,
or contracting,
depending on what the moment is.
And so I'm glad we got the
book done, but I was very,
very frustrated in trying to do the
book, in terms of finding photogenic
and photographic opportunities.
But the thing that someone
just mentioned to me,
that a Russian woman,
who is a journalist,
has come to America just
to have her child here.
She will return to Russia.
But she wants her child
to be an American citizen
so that he will be assured a freedom
if worst things happen in Russia,
and that's just something
to think about.
Imagine bringing another -- I
mean, she's not the only person.
Apparently it's a very
real phenomenon,
that to enjoy the benefits that we
have as Americans is so precious
that a woman would really
risk her lie traveling here,
just to make sure her son, or
child, or daughter was free.
>> Robert Newlen: Terrific.
I'm going to save the
Magna Carta question,
because I think you've
given such a great segway
to begin looking at the photographs.
So Verna?
>> Bob Adelman: Were you
going to comment on --
>> Robert Newlen: Yeah,
we'll come back.
>> Ira Glasser: Later.
>> Robert Newlen: Verna, can we
take a look at the first group?
And this first group of photographs
we're going to look at are all
about Martin Luther King.
>> Bob Adelman: That's
during the Selma march.
He was having foot trouble.
And in fact, he didn't march a
couple of days because of it.
And I particularly
like this picture,
because he looks sort of militant.
You know, when I first saw this
statue here, I didn't really
like it, because I always
thought he reached out to people,
but this statue here,
he's closed in.
But really, underneath all
that, he was very determined.
But in addition to that,
he was a master tactician.
You know, I think of the
Civil Rights Movement
as the last battles
of the Civil War.
And compared to the Civil
War, in which hundreds of --
I think 600 or 700,000 people
were killed in the war that,
in these last battles of the
civil rights, waged in major part
under Dr. King's direction.
There were very few casualties.
We all believed in non-violence.
>> Robert Newlen: Ira, what kind
of thoughts come to your mind
as we're looking at
Bob's photographs now?
>> Ira Glasser: How
much younger I was.
[laughter] I mean, I
grew up in New York,
and with that white liberal
illusion that many of us had,
that racism was a southern
phenomenon,
and all of this stuff was
going on in the south.
And the first big demonstration
I ever went
to was the March on
Washington in 1963.
And I was only 25 then, and I
was not yet working at the ACLU.
And the feeling of people, black
and white, marching together
in those numbers for what they were
marching for at that particular time
in your history was a
feeling that sort of can't --
it can be remembered, but
it can't be recaptured.
And it's something that if I talk
about to my grandchildren, who,
as they come of age, and this to
them is history, what that meant
at the time, what these
photographs document,
was a participatory feeling
of turbulence, and change,
and great things underway that
it was difficult to describe.
And these photographs, I don't
know if the slides include one,
but the ones particularly that Bob
did of the firehouses in Birmingham,
I remember what it felt
like to first see those
in the early '60s, there.
And that -- you know, I
remember thinking it reminded me
of an El Greco painting.
It was not just an
extraordinary documentation
of an extraordinary social struggle,
but the art of those
photographs was just incredible.
And I remember asking Bob for a
copy of this, which I had on my wall
in my apartment in New York
as my kids were growing up.
And every time they would
go back from the kitchen
to their bedroom, they
would see that.
And sooner or later, they
would ask me, "What was that?"
I mean, you couldn't even tell
what it was without explanation.
But to document that
sort of stuff in a way
that somebody's words could never
reproduce comes as close as possible
to capturing the feeling of what
it was like to sort of be alive
at that time and take part in it.
>> Robert Newlen: Terrific.
Verna, can we move
to our next section.
And this group photographs
deal with civil disobedience.
>> Bob Adelman: Well, you know, I
might say something about Dr. King
that maybe some of
you know or don't.
But, you know, he died at 39,
and he traveled 24 million
miles as part of his mission.
Most of that travel had to
do with going out to try
to fund civil rights activities.
He was arrested, I
think, more than 30 times.
Attacked numerous times.
And he, you know, of course,
led the movement in Birmingham.
That picture of the
hosing is actually --
Lillian Smith, the great southern
writer, told me we were going
to work together on
something that never,
unlike our book, didn't come about.
But anyway, she said, "Bob,"
she said, "don't pay attention
to what the whites are doing.
They're doing the same stuff."
She says, "It's the blacks
in the Civil Rights Movement
who are taking their bodies,"
which were chained, and beaten,
and slaved, "and they're
using their bodies.
They're going to sit down.
They're, you know,
standing up to vote."
And she said, "Just
watch what they're doing.
That's what's new.
The white people are just,
you know, resisting them."
And of course, she
also explained to me
that segregation wasn't
just separating the races.
It was an organized system of terror
to prevent blacks, essentially,
from voting, but from, you
know, enjoying the full equality
that we fought the Civil War
to, you know, bring about.
>> Robert Newlen: Can you
tell us what was happening
in this photograph?
>> Bob Adelman: Oh, well,
this is in Brooklyn, Ira.
[laughter]
>> Ira Glasser: It was there too.
Some of us didn't know
it, but it was there too.
>> Bob Adelman: It's
at a building site.
And this woman is preventing
a truck from exiting.
There was -- at that time, the
building trades were quite --
they were very good
jobs, well-paying jobs,
and they didn't have enough black
workers, and so they were protesting
that this was a state project or
something, building a hospital.
And so -- and of course,
why is this woman out there?
Well, if the men can't get jobs,
they can't be husbands,
they can't be fathers.
So anyway, they stopped
the trucks at that point.
>> Bob Adelman: That was a big issue
in New York that a lot of people
who regarded themselves as advocates
for racial justice, like me,
were not aware of for
a very long time.
I mean, the New York City,
particularly the construction
building trades,
was a locked down union town.
You could not have a job
in the building trades
if you were not a member
of the union.
And labor unions, because of
the heritage of what happened
in the '30s, labor unions were seen
as an instrument of social justice.
But in New York, they were an
instrument of racial exclusion.
My father was a construction worker,
and he grew up d during
the Depression.
And I still remember,
as a small boy,
that he hardly ever worked a
full week, and it was a struggle.
But the only reason he had a job
was because somebody black didn't,
because they were excluded
from the competition.
Even though there were
large numbers in New York,
they couldn't get into the union.
And if you couldn't get into
the union, you didn't work.
And I remember as a small boy
going to the union hiring hole
with my father and never noticing
that there weren't any
blacks there, ever.
And the reason I never noticed it is
because there weren't
any blacks anywhere.
Not in my school, not in the
stores where my mother shopped.
When I say not in my school, I
don't mean just not teachers.
Not students.
You know, New York was a
multiracial, multiethnic place,
but you lived in neighborhoods
that were entirely singular.
There were Czech neighborhoods,
and Polish neighborhoods,
and Irish Catholic neighborhoods.
I lived in a neighborhood where
if you came down from my building
and walked, you know, as far
as I could walk as a child
in any direction, you
never saw anybody
that wasn't white and
Jewish, you know.
So one of the things that happened
is that not seeing black folks
in places where they
were being excluded
from with dire consequences,
like the labor union holes,
or the voting lines, was not
unusual, so you didn't notice it.
And that's why all of that
stuff that we was going
on in the south was also going on
in the north in different ways,
but in ways in which the people who
supported racial justice movements
in the south managed to insulate
themselves from in the north.
And the man who changed
that was Jackie Robinson.
>> Robert Newlen: There you go.
There you go.
>> Ira Glasser: Because,
I mean, this was 1947.
This was what I like to call the
first great civil rights event
of the post-war era.
And it was an event -- I was nine
years old, and if you were trying
to teach me about this
stuff in school,
I probably would have glazed over.
But the Brooklyn Dodgers were the
most important thing in our lives,
and all of a sudden, we were
involved in this racial struggle.
And what mattered to us, you know --
I often said if the Yankees
had bought up Jackie Robinson,
I would have been a racist,
because we hated the Yankees.
[laughter].
And what was important to us was
not the color of a man's skin.
It was the color of his uniform.
[laughter].
And but of course, it was impossible
for the Yankees to have bought
up Jackie Robinson, because
the Yankees were a different --
we all knew that, you know,
if you were a Dodger fan,
you grew up to believe
in social justice.
If you were a Giants fan,
you were kind of confused.
But if you were a Yankee
fan, you grew up to believe
in oil depletion allowances.
And the Yankees were one of
the last teams to hire --
they didn't hire their first
black player till 1955, you know,
when almost every team
had every black players.
But the important thing
is that Robinson went
through all this stuff, that
if you saw that movie 42,
which was a pretty accurate
rendition of that history.
You're nine years old,
this is your favorite team,
and he was the most exciting player,
and this is your favorite player,
and they are tearing him up.
And the way I first learned
about racial exclusion in hotels
and restaurants was because
of hearing on the radio,
during the broadcast
of the Dodger games,
that when the Dodgers played
the Cardinals in St. Louis,
Jackie Robinson, and Roy Campanella,
and Don Newcombe had to stay
at a different hotel and
eat a different restaurant.
28:35 And that's how I came to
learn about racial exclusion
and public accommodation,
and that's why I hated it.
Nobody taught it to
me in moral terms.
Nobody -- you know, you
just -- this was your guy.
And it was an extraordinary
thing for --
people wrote later about what
Robinson meant as a role model
for black kids, but nobody wrote
for many, many decades what it meant
as a role model for white kids.
On my block, because
Robinson was our favorite,
we all imitated his batting stance,
his style of running the bases.
He became a hero to us.
This was something that what I later
called the integration of the soul.
I mean, it was an integration
that was going on psychologically
that we weren't even aware of.
And I was never aware of it
until I came, decades later,
to work at the ACLU, where I
discovered a strange thing,
which I first used to joke about,
and then I realized
was not an accident.
That was that every male person
who worked at the ACLU who was
about my age was an old Dodger fan.
[laughter].
There were no Yankee
fans at the ACLU.
[inaudible].
And that was -- and because one of
the things that happened is, also,
you went to Ebbets Field, and
Ebbets Field in 1947, '48,
'49 was probably the only integrated
public accommodation in the country,
because now, suddenly, black
folks came out to see Robinson.
And so I'm 9, 10, 11 years old.
I'm starting to go to
Ebbets Field by myself.
I go to the game, and
I'm sitting next
to a black guy about, I don't know.
He was 40.
He was in undershirt.
He was drinking beer, you know,
doing what baseball fans do.
And we were on the same side, and
we were rooting for the same things.
And when somebody did
something good on the Dodgers,
we were slapping each
other and hugging.
This was an experience that a
white boy could not have had
and did not have anywhere
else in this country.
And what it did is it
created a sense of humanity.
These were no longer
people who were others.
These were people who were us.
And none of this was conscious.
Nobody talked about it.
Nobody -- but that's what happened.
And this is the only place
where I ever saw black
folks in a normal setting.
I didn't see them in stores, or
in movies, or in voting lines,
or in union holes, or
in school, no place.
I saw them at Ebbets Field.
And it changed the country.
That's why it was a great civil
rights event before anybody
recognized it as such, and not
just a great baseball event.
And all of that stuff
that was happening
in the north was happening not
by law or the Ku Klux Klan.
It was happening by
custom, and acceptance,
and complicity, and blindness.
But it happened as strongly in the
north as it happened in the south.
And at the beginning of
the Civil Rights Movement,
nobody recognized that in the north.
And after they were told
about it, they denied it,
and it became a big -- and the
labor union stuff, and the business
about that woman blocking the
construction was all about that
in a way that was not
explicit or understood by a lot
of well-meaning white
folks at the time.
>> Robert Newlen: Wow.
Verna, can you go back to the
photograph of the soda fountain?
What was happening here?
>> Bob Adelman: Oh, this was in --
>> Ira Glasser: The
white tower, right?
>> Bob Adelman: Yeah,
White Castle in the Bronx.
And CORE was trying to get jobs
for, you know, black workers.
And there, the pickets
are outside, picketing,
though sometimes they came in
and sat in at the facility.
But, you know, people will
often say, "Well, you know what,
there was already discrimination,
and in the south, there
was segregation."
But in fact, at certain
points, you know,
denying somebody a job really means
often denying them a way of life.
And you know, this is how,
you know, crazy all this is.
Burning crosses in the
Bronx and all that.
But if a black family moved into
a predominantly white neighborhood
or bought a house, that house
could be fire bombed or,
you know, blown up.
So you know, the racial line was --
I mean, wasn't so different
on some bases.
>> Ira Glasser: And you know, until
I saw that photograph years later,
I didn't realize -- and I said,
you know, the March on Washington
in '63 was the first big
demonstration I ever went to.
This was the first
It was a few years earlier, and my
oldest friend and I went up there
to take part in this picket thing.
And you know, it was New York.
We weren't afraid.
And we went up there, and there,
you can see on those faces,
those are the same faces that you
see in pictures of Little Rock.
And it was scary, because it was
-- the violence was just palpable.
It didn't happen there, but
you could just feel it outside.
And as Bob says, you know, this
stuff was as present in New York,
and Philadelphia, and Chicago,
and Boston as it was in the south,
but in very different ways.
>> Robert Newlen: Verna, let's
move to the women's rights portion.
Okay, here we go.
>> Bob Adelman: Is
that where it starts?
Oh. Is this the first picture?
[inaudible].
Ah, yeah. Because that's
a very well-known picture.
This is, what, 1970?
>> Ira Glasser: '70 or '71, yeah.
>> Bob Adelman: Yeah, yeah, 1970.
And this was the first
women's right demonstration,
at least I know about.
And scholars have told me
that this is kind of one
of the definitive pictures
of the women protesting.
And the -- I mean, well [inaudible].
They were all girls in their
20s, young women in their 20s,
holding up this enormous banner.
It's going across Fifth Avenue, and
they're barely able to hold it up,
but they're determined, and
they had wonderful spirit.
Now, I guess -- what's the next
-- yeah, you see, that's the --
they're all in, and
they're full of fervor.
As we go through the pictures,
we will see more complications.
This is -- [laughter].
It was --
>> Ira Glasser: One of the ironies
of social justice equality movements
is that it demands the participation
in things you should
be opposing, you know.
One of my gay rights
activist friends
in New York has always railed to me
about his disquiet about the push
to have gay people in the
army, because he said,
"I don't want anybody
in the army," you know.
"Nothing good comes from that."
And you know -- and so this whole
-- but the point, of course,
is to overcome the
involuntary exclusion.
So what happens is you very often
get involved in pushing for things
that every other part of
you is active in opposing.
And so you had a lot of people
who were against the draft
in those early '70s [laughter], you
know, saying, "Let's draft women."
What?
>> Bob Adelman: I'll
give up my superiority.
[laughter].
>> Robert Newlen: For equality.
Verna, can you go back
to the photograph
of the [laughter] gentleman
with the hand gesture?
>> Ira Glasser: What does that say?
[inaudible].
[laughter].
>> Robert Newlen: Bob,
I have to ask you this.
He wasn't gesturing at you, was he?
>> Bob Adelman: No, no.
He was going at the --
the demonstrators are
marching down Fifth Avenue,
and he's in the crowd watching.
And I think he's saying,
"Fong goo [phonetic]."
I think --
>> Robert Newlen: There you go.
>> Bob Adelman: [laughter]
That's okay to say, right?
>> Ira Glasser: Yes,
it's a well-known New
York ethnic reference.
>> Robert Newlen: There you go.
There you go.
We were just bleeped on
the tape, but that's okay.
[laughter].
>> Bob Adelman: Oh, yeah.
We saw that.
>> Ira Glasser: One of the
things that's really interesting
about all demonstrations, and so
many of Bob's pictures show this,
is that the violent reaction that
peaceful demonstrators provoke
in people who are opposed to
the content of what they say.
You know, sometimes the violence
is by construction workers.
Sometimes the violence
was by men against women.
Sometimes it was by
whites against blacks.
straights against gays.
But it's always the same.
There's always this almost
deformed look of anger and hatred,
and impending imminent violence
that people who are opposed
to the content of what is
being said feel on the outside.
And all of those --
that's why it's very hard,
unless you've taken the pictures,
to know where they're from,
because there's something very
similar about all those faces.
Susan B. Anthony, by the way, was a
very big supporter of prohibition,
just to balance things out a little
bit, and all of the depredations
of liberty that that involves and
still involves in respect to drugs.
>> Bob Adelman: Well, there's, you
know -- here we are, 50 years later,
and that still hasn't been
-- women are getting, what 75
or 80% of the salaries of men?
>> Ira Glasser: Right.
It was 59 back then, so that's
what we call progress in America.
[laughter].
>> Robert Newlen: The thing
that impresses me so much, Bob,
about your photographs, it's
just, like, they're so fresh,
they could have been
taken yesterday.
And also, just the other
thing, how intimate they are.
How, you know, I really feel your
engagement in the photograph.
You're not a bystander.
You're a participant.
>> Bob Adelman: Well, I
photographed things I cared about.
I mean, it's very funny.
I taught photography for many years,
and whenever I had a
female photography student,
we'd have discussions about
what they should photograph.
I'd say, "Why don't you
try to photograph how
in your life you feel you're
not treated equally somehow?"
It's a great assignment,
but nobody ever did it.
Well, I think it's very, very hard,
and I couldn't do it quite that way.
[laughter].
And some of it, you
know, got pretty ugly.
The --
>> Ira Glasser: Yes.
>> Bob Adelman: But I always --
in my own field, two of the great
photographers I had the privilege
of being friends with were
Diane Arbus and Dorothy Lang.
And the idea of people not
being equal, very strange.
42:30
>> Robert Newlen: Verna, shall
we move to our last segment?
Which deals with gay rights,
and what a timely topic.
>> Bob Adelman: Oh,
I love this picture.
[laughter].
>> Ira Glasser: Yeah,
I never saw that one.
That's great.
>> Bob Adelman: You can see the
mother -- I mean, maybe I'm --
you' always interpret photographs.
But the mother is with her son.
Father, you see, he seems a little
more [inaudible] about this.
Or is -- do you read
it that way, or --
>> Robert Newlen: I do.
But God bless him, he's there.
>> Bob Adelman: Yeah.
[laughter].
>> Robert Newlen: That's
a great photo.
>> Bob Adelman: Well, this dates
back to the 1960s, you know,
when people -- this was during
an anti-war demonstration but,
you know, people say, "Oh, look
at all of this sudden change."
Well, this has been, you
know, since Stonewall.
But I mean, since the '60s, there
have been protests, and efforts,
and attempts to change laws
and give, you know, equality.
>> Ira Glasser: Yeah,
and one of the things
that is not well understand
still, I think,
is how infectious these
rights movements were,
that each one became
a model for the other.
And this was explicit.
I mean, I remember when gay people
first started coming to the ACLU
to ask about lawsuits, when high
school students first started coming
[inaudible], when prisoners, mental
patients, children in foster care.
All of these groups that were
somehow outside the protections
of the Bill of Rights.
The Civil Rights Movement became
a model for, "Well, what about me?
What about us?
Can we do the same thing?"
There was the disability movement.
I don't know if I saw
this in a picture of yours
or if I saw it somewhere else,
but there was this disability
rights demonstration in Syracuse,
New York in the mid '70s.
And there was a young person in
a wheelchair with a big poster
that said -- they were demonstrating
against the March of Dimes,
because the March of Dimes
had become very paternalistic,
and they had their
grievances, whatever they were.
And then of course,
there came a time when,
once polio was virtually conquered,
the March of Dimes became pass,
and people stopped caring about
contributing to disability,
and they wouldn't contribute
to disability rights movements.
And this kid had this big sign
that said, "You gave us your dimes.
Now we want our rights."
It was a great, you know,
sort of startled reaction
that everybody had.
And these movements
all fed on each other.
If you look at the history of
the development of the law,
and the litigation, and the cases,
and the Bill of Rights applying
to blacks, and then the Bill
of Rights applying to women,
and then the Bill of Rights applying
to prisoners, and then the Bill
of Rights applying
to mental patients,
and the Bill of Rights applying
to children in foster care.
Each time those cases came in,
they asked the same question.
"Well, why doesn't the
Bill of Rights apply to me?
Why can't a prisoner have the right
to free speech that's involved
in keeping a diary in which he's
critical in the prison ward?
Why can't," you know.
And so the issue of the First
Amendment as it applies in prisons.
And all of these cases
became precedents
for all these other cases.
So these movements
were never separated.
There were, to some extent, copycat.
They were, to some extent, taking
the lessons of one movement
and applying them to my problem.
And what happened in the '60s,
in a single summary phrase,
is that the Bill of Rights
became alive for people
to whom it had never applied,
and it happened over and over
and over again, and it happened
within a pretty brief period
of time, from about 1954,
when Brown against Board
of Education was decided, to 1973,
when Roe v. Wade was decided.
Virtually of the rights that we
wake up with every morning and take
for granted were established
as enforceable rights
for the first time in
that 20-year period.
And not just by the Supreme
Court, but by those movements,
which really forced
the issue on everybody.
Yeah, that's right.
>> Bob Adelman: I don't know --
I photographed important pictures
in Willowbrook, which helped
close that despicable facility
of the mentally retarded.
I was just reminding
Ira [inaudible].
>> Ira Glasser: Yeah, there's
a picture in the book of that.
>> Bob Adelman: But
these are Dykes on Bikes,
[laughter] who are a wonderful
addition to the protest.
>> Robert Newlen: Well, we
have about ten minutes left,
and I want to be respectful
of everyone's time.
First, I want to thank Bob and Ira
for this just amazing dialogue.
And I will start the applause.
[ Applause ]
And now I'd like to open
it to your questions.
And Cliff has a handheld mic.
Yes, ma'am.
>> Hi.
>> Robert Newlen: Oh,
let's give you a mic there.
>> Thank you.
During your experience, did you
ever talk to the people and find
out about what they were thinking?
For example, if you had talked
to me about the women's movement
and anything that I had
experienced, I would say,
during one of my interviews, the
question was, "How do you feel
about taking a job away from a
man who has to support a family?"
I also grew up where my father
said to me, "It's more important
to support the boys than the
women, because you're just going
to have babies, to go to college."
>> Ira Glasser: Well, you know,
the -- it has always been true,
especially with respect to jobs,
in an economy that has never
had enough jobs for everybody,
the people who have access
to the jobs always benefit
from the exclusion of the
people who are shut out.
When I used to talk
about affirmative action
to white college audiences,
who would ask about what they
called reverse discrimination,
because preference was
being given to blacks,
I would tell them my story.
And my story was, is that, as I said
earlier, my father took jobs away
from black construction
workers in New York
and never knew it,
and I never knew it.
But I'll tell you what,
he benefited by it.
I benefited by it.
And I came to understand
that because,
on the day before Jackie
Robinson came to the Dodgers,
there were 400 baseball jobs,
25 per team for eight teams.
And on the day he had a job,
one white person didn't.
And you could say that he took that
job away from the white person,
but the white person and
never should have had that job
if there was an open
competition among all the people
who were excluded for reasons
that had nothing to do with merit
or their ability to perform the job.
And nobody talked about
women taking jobs away
from men during World War Two, when
they were all over there fighting
and when our economy and the war
effort was supported by women,
who after the war, were thought
to be unsuited for the very jobs
that they were doing during the war.
I mean, so the same thing is
sort of always true, you know.
And what happens with
those kind of questions is
that they play victims off
against each other, you know.
When there are not enough jobs
to go around, it helps the people
who have them if whole classes
of people are excluded
from competing for them.
And it's always -- I mean,
the reason why poor whites
in the south were always supporters
of racial injustice in the south was
because the blacks were the
only people who were below them,
and their position in
the social and economic
and political hierarchy was
dependent upon the subjugation
of black people.
So they had an interest in
maintaining that subjugation.
And so the whole issue of taking
jobs away, taking housing away,
taking all that -- voting
is a perfect example.
If you're going to let blacks
vote, whites aren't going
to dominate the election.
If you're going to let --
I mean, women in this country
couldn't vote till 1920, remember.
This was the land of the
free and the home of the --
this was, you know, all men
are created equal, you know.
Turns out they really
did mean all men,
and they didn't even mean all men.
They didn't mean black men.
They didn't mean American
Indian men.
They didn't even mean white
men who didn't own property.
The narrowness of the application
of the rights that we regard today
as universal, the narrowness of
the groups to which they applied
and the groups who were
excluded and on the outside
of those protections
is still something
that most Americans
don't understand.
And we are all -- I mean, my
father was able to buy a home,
a suburban home, in 1950,
because he had a job
that black folks couldn't
compete with.
Then he was able to have that home
in the suburbs because he was able
to get a mortgage that black
folks were excluded from getting.
Then that home became the major form
of wealth for working class people
when they died and had bequest.
And so people like me, and
then subsequently my children
and my grandchildren, had
benefits, financial benefits,
along the way that were the direct
result of the fact that my father
in difficult economic times did
not have to compete with blacks.
Not for a home, not for a
mortgage, not for a job.
And that's how I get to go to
college, and that's how my kids get
to go to college, and that's how I
get a small inheritance from a house
that other people couldn't own.
And so when white,
of my kids generation
and my grandchildren's generation
who don't know any of this.
Talk about reverse discrimination
and how utterly unaware
of how they were the
beneficiaries of discrimination.
They say, "But I didn't
discriminate.
And you didn't discriminate.
You spent your whole life
fighting against that, Grandpa.
So why" -- but the fact
that we didn't discriminate,
the fact that we were
opposed to discrimination,
did not mean we didn't
benefit by it,
and that's where the moral
obligation comes from.
And that's really a matter,
as the generations pass on,
you have to find some way to
teach that, because there's no way
that kids who are ten years
old today could know about it.
[inaudible].
>> Robert Newlen: Bob,
you've got the last word.
Just tell us [inaudible].
Lovely. Gentlemen, thank you so much
for this extraordinary
collaboration.
Thank you for being here today.
[inaudible] book as
relevant today as it was
when you published it in 1991.
Thank you all.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.